>> So, here's a quiz using this notion of conditional
independence. So, bear with me for a second, because this is
a little bit weird the way that I wrote it. But,
what I'd like you to do is find a truth setting
for thunder and lightning. So like, true/true or true/false or false/true
or false/false. Such that, the following thing holds true. That the
probability that thunder takes on that value, given that lightning takes
on the value that you give, and the storm is true,
ends up equaling the probability that thunder takes on
that value given lightning takes on the value that you
gave and storm is false. Right, so a setting
here so that basically the value of storm doesn't matter.
>> So, whatever I put in the upper left box
has to be what I put in the lower left
box. What I put in the upper right box has
to be what I put in the lower right box.
>> Right and in fact we're just not going to give you boxes for the
other ones. We'll just give you the two top boxes and automatically fill in the
bottom box.
>> Okay, that seems reasonable.